like your perfect crime you laugh it's a
mixed bag the first time I listen to it
I actually hated it it was fine
I thought reputation was just awful I
[Music]
really liked reputation by Taylor Swift
really really liked it to me
reputation doesn't really sound like a
Taylor Swift album it sounds to me just
like a really kind of basic bland pop
album I thought it was boring and
repetitive there's not a song on there
that I hate if you don't like pop music
you're gonna hate reputation as time has
gone on I just find that she hasn't had
a lot of growth as an artist something
that a large entity denies that she was
off aware and it was really genuine she
was making fun of this person I know
that the media crafted it seemed like
she was in on the joke Taylor Swift's
whole personality it doesn't really
translate into 2017 she's kind of this
politically aware being but in her music
she makes a conscious decision not to
address that she's here to talk about
her relationships to talk about this
drama she's here to talk about how other
people have wronged her and it comes off
as really narcissistic and she can do
better than that I want a break from the
constant stream of breaking news and hot
takes at Taylor Swift is the person to
do that and I'm grateful for that I
would very much like to be excluded from
this narrative